hello there friends before we get into
today's episode I wanted to give a big
thank you to everyone who has supported
the podcast over the last couple of
weeks earlier this week the episode of
James clear landed the show in the top
50 podcasts worldwide which was a lovely
thing to wake up to on Tuesday morning
so thank you very much for sharing it
the feedback I've had over the last few
episodes has been so fantastic and yeah
I have to pinch myself every day to
realize that I actually get to share
oxygen or bandwidth sometimes with
literally some of the cleverest people
on the planet with that in mind I
thought I would give you a quick rundown
of some of the upcoming guests so on
Monday professor David Sinclair from
Harvard Medical School one of Time
Magazine's 50 most influential health
professionals on the planet talking
about whether or not a human can live to
be a thousand years old
Rachel Kleinfeld who advises the UK and
US government on how to govern correctly
Tim Briggs from we dominate nutrition
Tom MacGregor CEO of social chain is
back again
Theo and Eve from the social minds
podcast George McGill innovation lead at
media chain but today we're talking all
things money management with Chris
Hitchens who is the CEO and founder of
Grove he started a company called milk
which got acquired by Google in 2012 and
then he spent most of his time at Google
as a partner helping startups and
investing in early-stage companies so
this guy knows what he's talking about I
really enjoyed the conversation a car
white have him back on as well please
welcome Chris Hodgins
[Music]
mr. Chris Hutchins how are you I'm great
how are you welcome to the show man
thank you very very happy here very very
happy to have you on we're talking all
things money today right yes yeah it's
been like the obsession of my life well
I think it's the obsession of a lot of
people's lives right yeah yeah I mean
it's something that causes more stress
than anything else for most people yeah
I couldn't agree more
so for the listeners who don't know who
you are could you give us a bit of a
background sure where do I begin
you know the whole my whole life I've
been obsessed with money but more
professionally I spent the last you know
ten years in start-up land I got my
first job out of college thinking I
should go into Investment Banking and
management consulting and ultimately got
laid off which gave me this opportunity
to take what you know he's a very common
in America but effectively was like a
gap year later in life where I took
seven months with my now wife and we
traveled came back in about 2011 and was
like this is the industry I'm gonna work
in and have been working in Silicon
Valley for tech companies starting tech
companies sold a company to Google spent
some time at Google investing in
startups and you know have basically
lived my entire last decade in in worst
in Silicon Valley that must be pretty
crazy it seems like such a fuss to paste
very quickly moving environment it is
definitely that it is a wild place to be
you know companies are growing you know
I look back to you know I tried to pick
the hottest company to work at when I
first got back from my trip and it was a
company called simplegeo then ended up
not working out and my wife took a job
at a company that neither one of us were
all that convinced at the time you know
would be the biggest company you know
possible and you know now it's it grew
into lyft and she's been at lyft for
nine years and so it's one of those kind
of crazy adventures where you never know
what what's gonna happen you know it
might be six people in a small room that
you know now as a 5,000 person company
yeah totally I was reading an article
recently about
the electric scooter bird and the is it
lime is it lime scooters bird has them
lime spin scoot lift has move is getting
in that as well right they're trying to
buy someone and they've already I think
yeah they bought a company called jump
that has bikes and I don't know what
their scooter plan is but it's yeah it's
crazy you know you I was in LA this
weekend and there were so many scooters
everywhere
it was crazy yeah I went to LA last
summer and I couldn't I was like what is
this a trend that no one's told me about
like why is everyone whizzing around an
electric scooters but I was reading I
think it's towards the back end of last
year that the valuation on those
companies went like five hundred million
1 billion 10 billion like month on month
on month I think that was what happened
with bird or something like that it's
been really really crazy so I bird and
lime and yeah it's it's kind of wild I
don't even know how to think about it
but this must be maybe not to that kind
of degree but these crazy take offs must
kind of be 10 a penny in in Silicon
Valley there's always someone on the up
and someone on the down and yeah I mean
I spent about three years at Google
Ventures investing in companies and you
know we probably invested in 300
companies and the the time I was there
and you know every week month it's it's
you know a different trend you know one
month it's you know we've got to invest
in all there was four companies at one
point in time that helped you sell a
used car and it was like the hottest
market everyone was investing in
companies that helped you sell a used
car and you know now I don't think any
of those companies are around maybe one
of them is but you know it was such a
frenzy for a very short period of time
it was pretty crazy where were those
signals coming from you know this like
weird hype cycle of fear of missing out
and things happening at the same time
and people getting scared and you know
people seen big markets and
opportunities and not knowing how it'll
evolve and all that kind of comes from
everywhere but yeah it's pretty pretty
crazy yeah it must be it must have been
a bit of a baptism of fire or
in that particular department at Google
yeah it was awesome like you know you
just get to intimately see all the crazy
stuff that's happening and you know I
can't imagine anything better than you
know getting that exposure especially I
didn't know I wanted to start a company
after that but you know that was you
know great exposure to all the ups and
downs of entrepreneurial life before you
leave to go you know take on that job
again yeah it's like a 1.6 bar pressure
washer hose straight to the face like
high-volume startups right yeah I mean
where else do you get to learn about you
know I must have seen a thousand pitches
and you know we did a few hundred
investments it's just crazy
you know you get to see it all so if you
were to pick out some of the elements of
good pitches is there any any things
that stood out that you thought I need
to when I'm considering doing my own
stuff is there any principles from that
that you thought was super good yeah I
mean I think something sometimes people
overlook is that you know feces aren't
necessarily like the details of the
numbers at the early stage are secondary
to the person in the room and so you
know the whole thing starts with like is
this a person that can achieve this wild
ambitious thing and when that a wild
ambitious thing is so far away and so
big you know it's less about you showing
it here's how step by step the numbers
work over the next 10 years cuz like I
thought none of that is like ever gonna
actually be true it's more is this the
person that cares about this enough to
deal with all the crap that comes with
starting a company do they care about
this industry enough the problem they're
solving enough can they hire the right
people can they build the right team and
it's it really comes down to to the
founders and if you can buy into the
founders and they're not building
something in a tiny marketplace and you
have either the reason to believe that
they could build the product or they've
already demonstrated they can build it
like you know a lot of the other stuff
is much less important at the early
stage yeah so enough caffeine before you
go in like the
level of caffeine concentration in your
blood yeah you've got to be excited like
if that doesn't shine through you have
bigger problems like you have to be
passionate I always tell people like the
number one skill of a founder is
storytelling it's not you know there's
all these other things that matter but
if you can't walk into a room and tell a
story that gets people excited you know
you won't have the opportunity to talk
about your management skills or your
product skills or your marketing skills
yeah you got to get yourself through the
door first
Steve Bartlett's the CEO of social chain
over here in the UK which is a big
social media agency pretty much one of
the main reasons why that company has
been successful is because of Steve's
personality that they the guy's a social
chain and one of my buddies Peter was
like one of the first 10 employees and
this this company's massive now they've
got offices in New York and they're
expanding all over the world and they
did Manchester United's like marketing
campaign and etc etc and one of the main
areas of their marketing strategy is get
Steve in front of a big crowd of people
and then someone spend a lot of time on
his LinkedIn as soon as it finishes
because like that's what happens you put
him in a room and he just people just
gravitate towards him and he seems to
have that allure and and that energy
that sells people especially when you
think about a company like that and you
know a lot of the listeners may be
working in digital marketing social
media marketing or you know an easy side
hustle at the moment because I still
don't think it's a saturated market for
small businesses is to start doing
social media consulting like if you're
like a Gen Y yeah
and you've grown up on social media you
understand how it works
but there are within a 20 mile radius of
where you live right now there's
probably a hundred coffee shops and
cafes and sandwich bars and all the rest
of it who don't even have like a Google
or yell listing like they won't exist
online and you know a common site hustle
for those people is to is to be able to
get into this and for Steve to set
himself apart and to really convince the
old guard of marketing that social is a
way to go and they should strongly
consider portioning off a lot of their
income a lot of their marketing budget
towards that is just
selling how excited he gets about social
media he's like he's like yeah like a
like a young Gary Vaynerchuk from the UK
but less less way that's amazing yeah
Larry
Gary is like just a such an intense
personality I owe a lot to him for you
know pushing me I've known him for
easily over 10 years but yeah like some
people just have that ability to
captivate an audience at any point in
time and and can do a lot of good with
it that's fantastic
so we wanted to talk a little bit we had
a lot of requests for advice for
people's personal finances and I think
that as exciting as it is I do want to
hear some more stories from Google I
think we'll come back to that in a bit
but um a lot of people I I certainly
didn't learn basics of anything to do
with how I manage my own finances I
didn't understand before I went to uni I
didn't understand what an asset or a
liability was I didn't understand how a
mortgage worked or anything like that so
do you have some principles that you
stick to for your personal finances yeah
and first off like you're not alone
right you know it's whether it's the UK
or the US they're probably anywhere else
like we're not it doesn't seem like
anyone's getting taught these principles
in school and you know there was a world
that you know my parents kind of grew up
around but maybe didn't grow up in where
you know you work for a company for 30
years and that company takes care of you
for the rest of your life and you know
they pay for everything later and that's
great but it doesn't happen for us now
and with so many people being you know
freelancers and self-employed and you
know the average time I think people I
know change jobs is like you know three
or four years not 30 or 40 years so you
know we don't build up a pool of
retirement assets or pensions tied to a
company that's enough to sustain us so
we kind of really have to figure it out
on our own education just hasn't caught
up so it's kind of frustrating for a lot
of people I couldn't agree more the only
reason that I'm in any way slightly
capable with my finances is because I've
got two business partners who are
fantastic and there's been like a
trickle-down effect I've been kind of
begging in the gutter like just
desperate
trying to glean any last little second
nuance of understanding about how to
organize my money and then you know the
fact that I've managed to not bankrupt
myself is probably a testament to their
abilities yep that makes sense
so with regards to where people should
start on how they should consider or
look at their own personal finances
where do we begin man so you know I have
a typical like how do you think about
this where do you begin
concept which is like you know step one
is just like start to take ownership of
what you're thinking about you know
learn the concept of assets and
liabilities and you know summarize where
you're at
you know first first thing I think
everyone should start to do is just
understand where they're starting from
you know make a list of all the accounts
they have make a list of you know the
ones that have positive balances whether
that's brokerage or you know you know a
savings account or an investor
retirement account and then also look at
you know anything that's that's you know
falls into the debt camp you know
whether it's a credit card or a mortgage
or a loan you know when you add up all
the positives and subtract you know
everything else you end up with your net
worth which i think is something that a
lot of people have never taken the time
to look at but it's kind of like a core
thing to start with when you're trying
to figure figure out where you're going
yeah what what am I what's my current
worth yeah and then so I you know in
accounting terms we'd say like make your
balance sheet and income statement which
scares people so we'll avoid those for
the rest of this conversation but the
other one is just to figure out like how
much are you spending and saving you
know there's a lot of ways to do that
some people are really diligent and they
say I put everything on one credit card
and so you could just go look and say
well this is how much I spend and some
people aren't and they might need to use
a you know software to track it or you
know a spreadsheet there's a great app
called YNAB you know no affiliation to
them but YNAB calm you stands for you
need a budget it's a great like tool
that you can use to kind of forecast out
you know your spending and you know they
take this idea that I think is really
meaningful of you know allocating your
spending in advance which forces you
prioritize what you care about
interesting thing I learned was you know
I really value experiences and like you
know trying new things and whether
that's going to some kind of show or
taking a class but when I looked at my
spending last year I realized that it
made up like less than 1% of all my
spending and so my wife and I were like
well this isn't make sense like if this
is a thing we care about a lot why are
we spending more money in all these
other categories mm-hmm
so I tell people like step one is really
just figure out where you're at what
what is your total
you know sum of all of your assets minus
your debt and then what are you what are
you able to save or spend each month so
you can take what you earn you can take
what you spend and kind of look at the
difference and that kind of ultimately
ends up being how much you can save each
month yeah I've seen a number of adverts
for online banking facilities that will
break down your spending across multiple
different areas so it's like this much
on leisure and this much on food and
drink and this much on coffee or
whatever it is that coffee probably
actually makes a perfed proportion of a
lot of people's yearly spending I'm
gonna guess in Silicon Valley it'll be
like 20 percent yeah I mean it depends
if you were if we're gonna start up you
probably get free coffee but if you're a
freelancer you probably coffee is your
price of office space well if you like
that isn't it yeah yeah so you know it's
those that's the first step is just
where are you at because to kind of
think about anything down the road you
need to really figure out where you're
at you know I always think like a good
second step from figure out where you're
at but then it's like let's build a kind
of an initial foundation so the the
first thing that I think everyone should
probably do is put aside some type of
emergency fund you know if you have a
really really stable job working for the
government maybe it doesn't have to be
that big maybe it's you know two three
months of income if you are freelancing
and you never know where your next jobs
coming from maybe it should be six or
even twelve months yeah but you know set
aside some money that you know you can
be ready to weather whatever unexpected
expense or situation comes across
because the last thing you want to have
to do is have a situation arise and you
know sell retirement portfolio or you
know borrow money
and I always tell people that you know
I'd recommend putting it in a high-yield
savings account or something that aren't
some interest you know because if you
leave it at a checking account at the
bank it probably won't earn enough
interest I agree um you started up a
website right just after 2008 that was I
guess would have been similar to the
nightmare scenario that we're talking
about here if you get laid off yeah so I
started this thing called laid off camp
and we did events around the country
trying to help people figure out what to
do after the 2008 financial crisis and
you know I was fortunate that I had
saved up a little money so when I needed
to you know supplant my income with
something I had it but you know one of
the reasons a lot of people came to the
event was they were like I don't have
any money like and so yeah they can I
learn how to freelance how to start a
company how to get a job because you
know they didn't set aside an emergency
fund yeah of any of the any or many of
the guys and girls who you met at those
events have they gone on to do any cool
stuff or do you keep in contact with any
of the people who you met then yeah it
was really funny we're talking about at
my current startup you know a bunch of
different tactics for growth and my
co-founder handed me a book and he was
like you should read this book it's
amazing and I looked at the author and I
was like man that name so familiar I was
like oh my god this is this guy that got
laid off and he helped organize the laid
off camp in LA and like he went on to
become a well-known person in the gross
community and write a book and all this
stuff and I shot him a note and I was
like this is so wild congratulations all
that kind of stuff so yeah definitely I
keep randomly seeing people from from
that stage of my life go on to do
amazing things
that's so cool it's brilliant to turn
around a stick a big middle finger up at
people that laid you off by becoming
ridiculously successful yeah I mean you
know I think about that all the time
[Laughter]
yeah yeah we mean the co-hosts on the
show all self-employed or to one degree
or another and there's I think making it
on your own or going for it on your own
is a really cool idea for a lot of
people but the reality can be
it can be quite cutthroat I'm gonna
guess in Silicon Valley that's like the
the tip of the spear for four people in
cutthroat industries going off on their
own yeah I mean it's this thing that
almost maybe has become too sexy right
like everyone wants to start a company
and sometimes I meet people that you
know they just feel like it's the thing
they have to do and they haven't even
thought about it they're just like I got
to start a company that's what everyone
does and I'm well you don't have to
start a company like there are a lot of
other options but everyone's like I just
want to start a company I wanna start a
company so yeah it is kind of funny you
know I see that happening you know
wildly all over the place do you think
that that's a byproduct of people being
kind of disenchanted or disenfranchised
with their current work like if you have
a normal job where you don't feel like
you have a lot of meaning I was
listening to Johann Hari book lost
connections which is about the causes of
depression and in that he cites a
statistic that says 20% of Americans are
actively unhappy at their job actively
unengaged a further 60% are indifferent
and only 20% are actively engaged and
when you think that you're spending you
know between 35 and maybe 50 60 hours a
week doing this particular thing and it
forms the basis for who you are right
like when you meet someone the questions
you ask is like what's your name where
are you where are you from and what do
you do it's like your name and what you
do are like they might as well be the
same thing right that's hi my name is
Chris I'm a club promoter blah blah blah
whatever it might be and I think that
people being so unhappy with that leads
them to kind of maybe knee-jerk in the
opposite direction and go right well
what's the exact opposite of what I'm
doing now because if I'm unhappy doing
this then the right thing must be
complete opposite I start company yeah
it's a it's funny it's kind of been this
weird shift where I'm not convinced that
30 years ago people thought about it
like that right like you know it seemed
like everyone I've talked to you know
that's been in the workforce for twenty
thirty years the the idea is like you
work to live and
you know now there's this mind shift of
like no no no I have a lot of freedom
and responsibility over what I do I'm
gonna live to work and you know I want
to be fulfilled every day of my life and
you know that sometimes has a problem
with personal finance because you know
if you're like I don't love this job so
I shouldn't do it it's like okay that
might be true but you also need to be
able to provide for your family you need
to save for the future I meet people in
their 30s and sometimes I'm like hey you
know how long do you want to live you
know how long do you think you're gonna
live in there I don't know 100 and I'm
like okay well you know that if you're
you know 30 right now and you're gonna
work till you're 65 and then live to a
hundred like in the next 35 years you
have to save enough money to live for 35
more years you know like it's crazy that
you know you end up needing to save like
you know almost as many years as you
work you need to save for and a lot of
people like will when I retire that's
what I'm gonna travel I'm like okay well
your expenses are gonna go up so you
need to save even more so it's just you
know I think people need to find a
balance of like you know working -
everyone should try to be fulfilled in
their work and do something they're
excited about but not lose sight of the
fact that they also probably have some
responsibilities to themselves to their
family that you know sometimes I think
might come in the way of you know trying
to find the dream job which you know I
worry that there isn't really ever the
dream job yeah the the analogy of the it
being too sexy of an idea like it is the
hot new girl at school they're like
everybody everybody wants to wants to be
going out with you are you are totally
right
so we've talked about understanding our
current sort of capital worth we've
spoken about trying to forecast as well
look at where we're at now and then also
forecast that forwards how much money we
got coming in how much money we got
going out what would you advise for
people who were thinking right okay I've
got myself to that stage what goes comes
next
yeah so the two big things I think that
come next are like make sure you don't
have any high interest yet it's amazing
how often I find people that have the
means to pay off high interest debt but
haven't for reasons that you know they
never did the math right people don't
think about math you know finances like
spreadsheets or like I would and you
know so I went in and you know looked at
the situation I was like you have credit
card debt it's at 22% interest like you
have the money to pay it off why aren't
you paying it off and the answer
sometimes it's like well I didn't want
to dip into my savings and I'd say well
is your savings earning 22% and they're
like no no it's only 1% I'm like well
then you should definitely definitely
like pay off your 22% debt so with your
intro savings it's only earning 1% but
you know it's not something that people
always think about so like a big so set
aside some money in case something
happens
pay off high interest debt whether
that's credit cards personal loans that
kind of stuff and then the other is like
make sure you kind of dial up retirement
contributions you know you can't wait
till you're retired just you know get
the tax benefits of a lot of different
retirement contributions and so you know
whether that's pensions in the UK 401
k's in the u.s. you know you know I
think in Australia you get
superannuation and your company does it
all for you which is great but okay here
if you don't put money in in one year
you can't get that credit for the next
year like you're capped each year at how
much money you can set aside for
retirement tax-free so you know
encourage people to sure that they do
that early because you can't you can't
play catch-up like like you might wish
you could later like over payment sort
of it can you briefly cuz I the only
time that I've heard 401 K mentioned is
in die hard 4.0 like that's that's like
the honest I've ever heard it mentioned
can you for the Brits that are listening
can you briefly explain what it is how
it works
yeah 401ks right a lot I just lost audio
for one second I was like when you said
that one word yeah so in the u.s. we
have this system where you can put aside
a certain amount of money each year you
can choose whether you want to pay the
taxes now and never again or not now and
when you retire so you know in the u.s.
you're allowed to contribute personally
tax-free up to it keeps changing every
year but about $19,000 a year
and so you had their employer-sponsored
plans so that you know if you're
self-employed there's a whole different
system and if you work in a government
entity there's only yet another
different system if you work for an
educational come like a teacher there's
a different system but the most common
one for working at private companies is
a 401k and it's just an account that you
can put money in invest those funds in
mutual funds you know whatever whether
it's stocks or bonds or real estate and
you know at the end the most common one
is you put your money in tax-free while
you're working and then you earn all the
you know capital gains and interest over
time and then when you retire you only
pay taxes when you take the money out
and presumably the the idea would be
that you know when you're working you're
in a higher tax bracket than when you're
not working so you get both the benefits
of being able to invest your money you
know before you pay the taxes and not
have you know pain hopefully lower taxes
when you take it out oh yeah awesome
that's a really really good set up I
don't I don't fully understand how the
UK pension scheme works it's not a
million miles away from that but I I
don't know about the caps I don't know
about the 19 thousand what mad though
like you think like if you even if you
take 19 thousand if that's the maximum
that you can save if you if you don't
have surplus income on top of what
you're earning per year except for that
for a retirement fund and we roll
forward the 35 years to earn 70 years of
living analogy that you used earlier on
like $19,000 he goes like you're gonna
have to really get up towards that right
yeah so you know there's some
interesting things about compound
interest you know the best example I
have is you know if you had two friends
and one of them was saving $3,000 a year
from 25 to 35 and then stopped they just
saved 3,000 a year for 10 years yeah and
you've got another friend that saved
$3,000 a year starting when they were 35
all the way till 70 and so they're
saving for 35 years and the other person
saving for 10 years you know the first
person ended up contributing $30,000 to
their savings the next person
contributed 105
if those accounts grew at 7% a year the
friend that put in the 30,000 in for
only 10 years would have more money than
the person who put in three thousand
dollars a year for thirty five years so
the ending the math you know it ends up
that that ten that money can grow so
much more because the interest is
growing for longer and you started it
earlier so I would say you know if you
put in nineteen thousand dollars a year
for thirty years you're gonna end up
with a lot more than you know thirty
times nineteen thousand but if you wait
till you're you know five years from
retirement to start savings you don't
have to start saving you don't have the
time to benefit from all that compound
interest yeah I get that completely so
would you recommend or how much do you
tend to recommend to people to try and
have multiple revenues of multiple
income streams yeah so you know I think
I might deviate from like the zeitgeist
of like internet money hackers that are
like find your side hustle find your
multiple streams of income buy rental
properties like you know I have two
income streams right I have a job and I
have an investment portfolio and in that
investment portfolio I might invest in
stocks I might invest in REIT funds
which are you know kind of effectively
investing in a fund that holds a bunch
of pieces of a bunch of companies that
own property and they all rent them out
so you know I've chosen to say instead
of me managing a rental property instead
of me managing owning a small piece of
ten different startups I'm going to
invest in a diverse portfolio with a
bunch of index funds that invest in all
of those things so sure you could say I
have you know of thousands of income
streams because I'm invested in a
thousands of companies but you know
effectively I have an investment
portfolio and a job I'm not personally
you know trying to do anything else
running a company here's enough work for
me that I'm not trying to you know have
seventh I'd hustles yeah but yeah I mean
is it's a it's a balance I suppose
between the time you have available yeah
and also how much money you want like if
money's not much money
a big deal to you then like just do your
minimum effective dose to live and then
spend the rest of your time like chili
now yeah so I always say like step one
is figure out where you're at step two
is kind of build your foundation but
then step three is like actually make a
plan right so what are your goals if
your goal is to own a Ferrari well you
might need to save more money but if
your goal is just to like live a
comfortable life with your family and
you know the extra money that you could
save might prevent you from spending
time with them like you might not
actually want to go get that side hustle
yes yeah because I always say like what
do you want how do you want to retire
really early do you want to buy a home
like you know do you want to start a
company do you want to pay for your kids
to go to a private university like
what's the most important thing to you
and when you prioritize those things and
kind of figure out what they involve
like that's when you can make real
decisions but if you've never really
thought of it you know sometimes I see
people spending money when they haven't
realized that they care about things
more than spending ray you mentioned
coffee let's say you go buy your five
dollar latte every morning sum that up
over the year and you're like wow you
know that's actually you know could have
been you know a couple thousand dollars
maybe yeah but if you ask the someone
say hey you know do you is that coffee
does that get you through the day enough
that it's worth you know you know over a
decade or so being able to save up your
part of your kids education and someone
might say oh my gosh when I think about
it like that no but before I hadn't made
any plans and so I wasn't thinking about
it in any way and I think that's where
it gets really tough as if people aren't
thinking through all these things in
advance I couldn't agree more so my
business partner Darrin and the guys in
the office that are listening right now
will know what I'm going to say but
Darren's ethos is always that if you
times any number by 52 it becomes
[ __ ] massive and it's like when when
we're looking at a set of company
accounts in Malawi well we could we
could chip this off here or we could
knock a couple of hours off there and at
the time it doesn't really feel like
that big of a deal but like if we can
save five quid across four shifts on one
particular club night 2,000 pounds a
year let at the end of the year there is
1,000
and more because we have we we knocked
four by five pounds off a couple of
shift once a week and you like a holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that's so much money I
know that that's literally the most
basic of maths it's 20 times 50 but it's
just so much money yeah like yeah it's a
it's really easy to think you know we
think about that you know how much money
do we want to spend we provide lunches
at the office and we were like well you
know when we were small it didn't really
matter whether we went to a place and it
was you know 10 bucks or 12 bucks like
they're eight bucks it didn't matter but
we're like wow when you multiply five
lunches a day by 20 employees by you
know 50 you know five days a week times
you know 52 weeks like all of a sudden
you're like wow if we can cut a dollar
per lunch off we save a lot of money
yeah you're giving my business partner
an aneurysm now at the moment with him
hearing this hearing those figures so in
terms of we've spoken about the fact
that generating extra streams of revenue
you might not be something that's for
everyone but I'm going to guess that
dialing down your spending or at least
not having frivolous spending is a
principle that most people probably
should and could stick to have you got
any sort of hacks or principles that you
like to use when it comes to tightening
the sort of belt buckle so to speak yeah
I mean I would say it's not necessarily
all of the spending right it's not I
wouldn't say frivolous spending well
frivolous by nature probably you know
that word might imply that it's not
necessary but there are some people that
if you look at you know if you've
already figured out what you need to
save and you're already on track for it
you know what you might be able to do by
saving another thousand dollars a year
might not be worth it right like you
might say it for me you know for me to
cut another $3,000 out might mean I
can't take another vacation and what
would I get from saving 3,000 more
dollars a year maybe what that gets me
is like you know slightly better
lifestyle and retirement but if I've
already saved enough to live the
lifestyle I want in retirement maybe the
best
is to keep spending the money on travel
yeah but it's my thoughts of making a
plug right exactly if you haven't
figured that out you know for most
people they haven't figured that out for
most people they're probably not saving
as much as they should and so you know
broadly speaking yes it's a very common
that I talk to people and a good thing
for them to do is to spend less money I
just don't want to make the blanket
statement because for some people you
know keeping their current level of
spending or potentially even increasing
it you know I'm so frugal with money
that I have friends that are like you
realize like if you just you know die
and have all this money but you've never
spent it you wouldn't have lived a good
life like why don't you live a little
like you know why don't you you know get
the nice entree instead of like you know
split it with your wife because you
don't want to spend the extra 20 bucks
you know so I couldn't agree I'm just
this crazy optimizer that you know
probably could afford to not optimize as
much and you know optimize for
convenience and so even though we can
bring dogs to work I finally buckle down
and hired someone to come walk our dog
during the day because you know I could
just get so much more done when I'm not
thinking about having to leave and take
the dog out and schedule meetings around
it so it's just hard when you know my
what brain has just wired so much
differently to save every dollar yeah I
got also haven't you dog in the office
is gonna be like yeah it might be
distracting but it's fun like it's like
yeah it's nice to have dogs around right
that morale good little life I think
Mariah though at some point you're like
oh wow we have so many people that work
here maybe the problem is like we can't
have a dog in the office every day
because you know people are allergic
like all these things when you're a
small company that you don't think about
now you become a big company in York
well we have 30 people like maybe
someone's actually allergic to dogs so
we can't have a dog in office don't hire
them if someone if just no they're not
allowed they have to sit in their own
cubicle over the far side and everyone
else can play with the dog that's so
that's how I think it would work but
yeah I totally get what you mean I think
I'm wired a similar way to yourself I
remember a couple of years ago in as
like 2:00 in the morning after I'd
finished work at one of our club nights
it's 2:00 a.m.
and I'm looking at the difference
between like the value yogurt and like
the finest yogurt and I'm like having an
existential crisis about which of these
yogurt do I would get the value or well
I mean it's 20 25 pence more to get you
know I'm stopped and kind of checked
myself and I was like what on earth are
you doing like just just pay 25 pence
like you work so much just put the 25
pence yogurt into your basket and get
out it's to 2:00 a.m. but yeah people
tend to be wide in one of two ways I
think and you've got the ones who were
maybe on our side fighting about the
yogurt and then you've got some people
who maybe maybe could do with tightening
up a little bit
yep yeah I am the same way and it's my
people or think I'm crazy but you know
I've got like 15 different credit cards
and I decide which one and you know to
use based on whether it earns more
points on certain things
Wow that is okay yeah that's that's a
nother level so I wanted to wait to move
on to the company that you're right now
I wanted you to give us a little bit of
background about that and and and tell
us what's going on yeah yeah so right
now I left Google about two years ago to
start a company called Grove and you
know what we realized was no matter how
much I wanted people to build cash flow
models for themselves and forecast out
all their spending you know the reality
is many people you know I get enough
overwhelmed with personal finance that
they're not going to do their own
financial planning without some help and
the industry has evolved to a place
where the only support is for people who
already have a million dollars you know
that's the industry's like we'll manage
your money but only if you have a lot
and if you don't have a lot maybe we'll
work with you but we're gonna charge you
you know a few thousand dollars a year
and everyone doing this is you know old
school and you know prints out hundred
page documents and so the vision was how
do you build a company that uses enough
technology to make financial planners
efficient enough that when someone says
you know I want help I want to figure
out what I should be doing with my money
I want to organize things I want to you
know talk to someone about my goals so
that we can put together
and make sure I'm on track like we can
offer that to you for less you know less
than half the cost of the the rest of
the industry because you know they're
still doing in-person meetings and
having you write things on pieces of
paper and you know scanning them in and
you know so we built our own technology
stack that lets our team of financial
planners work with people at much less
much less the cost than a traditional
financial planner I yeah it blows my
mind that that isn't more common like
yes absolutely blows my mind everyone
you've already said most people don't
have a natural ability unless you are my
business partner but he's a freak of
nature and he was he was born like with
a laptop building spreadsheets if you
have if you're not wired like him or
yourself like where do you learn this
stuff from like you have to be deep down
in the medium archives or living on
reddit or like God knows where to be
able to get this so the fact that you
can't and you are right as well like you
think financial planner you're like oh
my god
velour curtains and a Montblanc pen and
a Chesterfield red sofa and a smoking
jacket and oak everywhere in this huge
big building you do you think like oh
it's it's built for millionaires yeah
it's so I always say like if you don't
have a million dollars or you don't want
to spend thousands of dollars a year and
you don't want to learn it yourself
you're kind of out of luck like there
isn't really a good alternative so that
was why we started the company we
thought that there should be an
alternative there should be a company
out there built from the ground up with
you know the responsibilities of putting
a customer's interest in first I don't
know how this is in the UK but in the US
there's this rule called the fiduciary
rule and you know it doesn't it's not a
mandate which so the fiduciary
responsibility means you're required to
act in your customers best interest haha
I've heard of that on movies before yeah
it is not required that financial
advisors in the u.s. be fiduciaries so
nine out of ten financial advisors in
the US are not required or do not hold
themselves to a standard of acting and
their customers best interest at all
times whose best interest to the acting
in often the companies so it's totally
legal in
u.s. to be a financial adviser and
recommend products that cost twice as
much as other products and you make the
money that's the difference totally fine
and that's how the industry's evolved so
when we started the company we're like
well we're not gonna do that so we
decided we're gonna be fiduciaries we're
gonna always act in our customers best
interest we're not gonna make money
selling other products like most of the
people in the industry do and that's
rare unfortunately but it's kind of what
we believe in so I'd love to find out
anyone who knows whether or not this is
the same in the UK please do drop me a
message and let me know because if it's
if that is the same in the UK that is
such a stupid loophole like yeah they
they tried to pass a law in the US last
year or the year before and it didn't
get anywhere and it was gonna require
that anyone that helps people with their
retirement plans is required to act in
their clients best interests the problem
is there's like 20 giant institutions in
the u.s. that would just go out of
business instantly because their entire
business is selling people things that
don't meet that level of responsibility
this is like a big big companies big big
financial institutions like ones you
know like the entire business is built
on selling life insurance policies for
you this is blowing my mind like it
sounds to me like the financial services
equivalent of medical and fire companies
advertising on TV like that like you do
not necessarily need this particular
thing but we're gonna force it down your
neck in any case like I that's how it
seems to me we don't have that in the UK
we don't have the the big farmer
advertising stuff in there and I'm
really really hoping that we don't have
financial advisors that really give
advice that's like just sniffing people
and get paid for it
it's totally legal for me to say pay me
and I will give you advice but I'll turn
around and sell you something that you
might not need it has to be what I
forgot what the exact term is it has to
be like directionally right so if you
tell me that you want to invest in the
stock market I can't sell you a bond
right right but if you say you want to
take a long-term risk and that's aligned
with stock mark
I can say my company offers a fund that
is not very different from the fund that
has no fees and our one-hour fun takes
two percent of your money every year
that's totally fine as long as it's
directionally you know it can't be the
wrong type of investment so it's crazy
one
you know they I keep hearing that states
might start trying to pass these laws
themselves because they can't get it
passed at the federal level yeah but
yeah it's unfortunate it's just a
byproduct of being a huge big new
country I suppose isn't it and this
there's a there's a lot of a lot of
problems for trying to get that sort of
stuff passed but I you know that is
that's scary like when you think that
that could be it's not gonna be mine
because my mom and dad are both British
that could be someone's mum and dad like
that could be their retirement fund that
could have been them working now it
usually is and I think you know I'm
gonna go in with my paycheck and I'm
gonna speak to this guy and he's gonna
be charming and then he's gonna give me
this information that's gonna completely
screw me over
so I mean was there not was that did no
one tighten up after 2008 with stuff
like that they tighten the company's
tightened up to make sure the banks
didn't lose more money but ya know I I
just I pulled up an article says
currently advisers in the UK are bound
by the FCA's conduct of business rules
but have no formal legal duty to act in
the best interest of the clients at all
times so that does it you know that was
my you know quick ten-second research so
it's if if it's happening in the US it
makes me it makes me think it very well
might be happening here so if you're
using a financial adviser for the love
of God please double check what they're
suggesting that you do is there any yeah
I'm gonna guess that you will be an
anomaly in the industry with having this
fiduciary kind of commitment yeah so
still the good news is like one in ten
advisors in the US do take on a
fiduciary responsibility of their
clients at all times you know in the
u.s. it's often called a fee-only
advisor meaning we only we only make
money from the fees our clients pay us
it's actually pretty easy in the US if
you just ask
your financial advisor say are you a
fiduciary you get one of two answers yes
or you get this weird answer that's like
we really care about it there's a
there's a john oliver who does a show on
HBO skit all about you know finance and
retirement plans and the fiduciary
responsibilities that's quite funny
digging into how crazy it is and how
possible it is for people to say they're
acting your best interest but not so I
would say if you're ever going to hire
someone to help you with money just dig
into this and like really understand the
the legal you know obligations they're
taking on and you know I would encourage
people that if your financial adviser is
not taking on a responsibility to
legally act in your best interest and I
don't mean like I care about you I mean
legally if you ever determined that I
sold you something that wasn't in your
best interest like there is a legal
responsibility I have and you can you
know fight that yeah yeah I mean I
that's the first thing you go ask surely
like are you are you gonna be the guy
who takes my money are you gonna be the
guy that makes me money like yeah but
you would be surprised at how good a
Salesman can answer the question of are
you acting in my best interest slippery
and sneaky answer yeah it's unfortunate
I wish there was just like a like a
health score you know you walk in a
restaurant and you're like oh you have a
D I don't want to eat here but like you
know there's no imagine if every
financial adviser just had to like put a
red X on their forehead if they didn't
act in your best interest to be great
that would be much easier there's a
speaking of the hygiene ratings there is
a subway right in the middle of
Newcastle which scored a zero stars out
of five food hygiene rating for anyone
now for anyone who's eaten at this
subway on the bottom of Collingwood
Street it is my belief I don't get sued
here but it is my belief that upon one
of their most recent food hygiene checks
they got zero stars out of five I mean I
don't even know how that's possible
yeah I don't know yeah but that's the
that's the food equivalent of the
financial service manager who's just
taking your money so um one thing that I
did know it's very briefly before we go
on you're medium you were talking about
hacking a peloton
a bike thing and yeah for the listeners
who don't know peloton's kind of like
live guided cycle workout that you do at
home and there's a screen and there's
like a train it's kind of like spinning
class but you don't actually have the
person there in front of you right yeah
yeah it's like doing SoulCycle or
something like that in your living room
yeah and you know I don't being an
entrepreneur you don't have a lot of
time I'm working all the time so I
didn't have you know I wasn't taking
taking the time to go to a fitness class
and everyone you know was talking about
peloton these bikes are beautiful but
you can actually get all their classes
on the app for you know way less
expensively than buying this two
thousand dollar bike and so I went on
the adventure of buying a spin bike and
you know attaching a couple different
Bluetooth trackers to it and mounting an
iPhone to it and you know connecting it
with airplay so I could watch the course
the class on my TV and the irony behind
this whole thing which I feel guilty
about is that a friend of mine who had a
peloton moved and sold me it used and I
gotta say as much as I want to be like
the man of the people and say you know
build it yourself the real thing is so
good I'm not sure I can tell you to pay
full price because it's so expensive but
you know it's like there's you could
find 10 smartphones that tell you they
do every single feature the same as
another one yeah but at the end of the I
still have an iPhone yeah so you know
one of those things it's it's when you
stuck between a rock and a hard place
and the thing is as well the degree of
satisfaction that you will get from
being so frugal like the the inherent
joy of like blasting the system and
being like no no [ __ ] you like mine
costs 175 dollars and yours was 2,000
it's gonna be worth it's gonna be worth
a lot but you think like the real things
just nice and it's there and it's ready
yeah I don't think I realized so what I
would say is if I hadn't realized how
driven I am by
the one thing building your own peloton
won't let you do is it won't log your
you know your workouts in the app
because the bike is not actually
connected to peloton yes so one time I
was staying at a hotel that had a
peloton and I got on a ride and I saw
real time like my friends stats versus
mine and I was like man in that one bike
ride he was like a little bit better and
I was like I'm gonna do the same thing
tomorrow morning I'm gonna destroy him
like I am just like out cycle him and
that moment I was like oh my gosh I
think I burned 20% more calories in a
workout knowing that I was trying to
beat my friend than I did before
and I was like I will pay for something
that allows me to get 20% more workout
at the same time yeah but I have friends
that like they have a real peloton and
they're like oh I don't like riding with
friends I don't like the competition
like oh you should definitely make a
fake one home I've got this one that
I've already built it's a like old
Bluetooth and there's airplay and all
this sort of stuff
so I think what to a nice concluding
note there is that we can say save money
but save money in the right place and
not in there yeah make make sure that
the places you're saving money are
driven by what you care about and so I
you know there are people that might
have I'll spend a lot of money on
fitness but it's really important to
them and like that's fine
yeah like the reality is if Fitness is
more important to you than where that
money could go that might not be a bad
use of it but if you haven't figured out
whether you know it you know you need
that money to do something more
important three years five years ten
years whether it's buy a home or start a
family like it's really hard to make
those decisions and you know the
unfortunate thing is the best way to do
it is to build a cash flow model for the
future of your life and you know run a
bunch of simulations which effectively
is the software we've built for our
advisers but you know so there's any a
basic way to like at least evaluate your
goals and think about them and if you
want to take it to the next step think
about working with someone who can help
do it for you if if you're not gonna go
build the models yourself yeah I mean
building financial forecasting models
does sound like for me the least fun
afternoon in the
but obviously for me like an adventure
that's you that's heaven for you you're
just bathing in financial forecast
models and expert excel sheets fall from
the sky so finally one thing I wanted to
finish on Chris are there any resources
or blogs or websites that are accessible
to the avatar of the layperson that you
think would be good for people to check
on or have you got any resources that
you guys offer yeah I mean you know we
have a service that you're welcome to
check out if you're based in the US at
hello Grove comm you know there's a
bunch of good books you know they just
talk about the basics and honestly you
know your personality you know the style
you're interested in it almost doesn't
matter find the book that speaks to you
the most find the blog that speaks to
you the most you know if you're really
into retiring or early it might be
mister money mustache you know there's a
movie coming out later this year called
playing with fire that kind of really
dives into the movement of people trying
to retire early
and seek financial independence you know
ultimately what matters is that you're
you're excited and motivated by it so
instead of picking a resource that I
think is really good I'll say pick
whatever resource speaks to you yeah but
I will say take a look at the book happy
money which is kind of like a
psychological evaluation of ways to
spend money to actually increase your
happiness and it's shocking how much
just reading this quick like you know it
seems like a hundred page book might
change your perspective on spending and
focus you on like how can you make sure
that you're using money to fulfill your
life and not just to perpetuate things
that you're doing for no reason that's
an awesome idea
I love that I'm gonna guess that that
would have been one of the spurring on
moments for yourself when it came to
looking at the experiences in life and
then realizing that it was like 1% of
your annual spending yeah yeah it's just
you know you identify these things that
can actually bring fulfillment to life
which as you mentioned earlier is what
we're all seeking and so if someone's
gonna go do you know hundreds and
hundreds of hours of research on how you
can apply your money towards you know
fulfilling your life like
yeah I'd rather read the book then go do
the research myself couldn't agree more
so Chris before you go can you tell the
listeners where they can find you online
where they can learn out more about
yourself
yeah I'm Chris Hutchins dot-com is my my
personal site Hutchins on Twitter and
then Grove is just hello Grove calm
amazing mind it's been an absolute blast
thank you very much yeah thanks so much
[Music]
you